how many of you feel like I've made this
talk before several hundred times I made
it yesterday
you know what I did between yesterday
and today I spent over six hours getting
ready for the day you see I think it
would be arrogant if I thought I could
stand up and spit it out just because I
did it yesterday are hundreds of times
that's arrogance that's when Buster
Douglas knocks out Mike Tyson that's
when an expansion team in Houston beats
an established NFL team in Dallas
I dare not look at the people here
several thousand I'm taking over an hour
to that several panels and hours of time
where would my integrity be if I came
here unprepared to make something a
presentation that could make a
difference in your life there is no way
you gotta prepare for it ladies and
gentlemen almost did not go to the most
important sales meeting that morning I
awaken five o'clock the alarm clock goes
off and it was an alarm clock in those
days now it's an opportunity clock if
I'm here that means I've got an
opportunity to get up and go when the
clock went off you know I looked at and
I said no sane person would ever get in
a little Altima bill without a heater in
weather like this and drive all the way
to Charlotte to go to another meeting so
I lay back down
as I lay down the words of my mother
came back to me son if you work for a
man you work for him all the way you're
loyal to him in every way and if your
word is no good you're no good I had
promised this company which had taken me
two months to get the job that if they
would give me the opportunity I'd be at
ever sales meeting I'd be at every
training session and in two and a half
years despite my lack of success I'd
been at every sales meeting at every
training session and I've never even
been late the words that my mother came
back I rolled out of bed went to the
meeting that's the one that changed my
life it changed my life because that's
the day that mr. marrow persuaded me
that I could be the champion
that's what made all the difference in
the world you just watch - amazing clips
from Zig Ziglar take the next three
minutes and sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you